back to school this morning more clark
county students are going back on campus
thousands of children are back in class
after more than a year of remote
learning
hector mejia live this morning for us up
at centennial high in the far northwest
valley with some details hector good
morning to you
[Music]
hey there john good morning here's how
excited students are just a few minutes
ago i saw a student
singing her heart out in her car while
she put her makeup on before making it
to class so here we are at centennial
high school
where we have go dogs and we have
cheerleaders out here
all getting ready to welcome so many
students back it's a big celebration out
here
and it's sort of a mixed bag at the
school district some grade levels are
returning for the first time
others are joining their peers who
started last month but the bottom line
is
more grade levels are returning to
face-to-face instruction here in the
valley
all elementary schools will have will
start in-person learning
five days a week as well as increase
classroom capacity up to 75 percent
the state allows this change after a
campus completes 20 days of some form of
in-person instruction
some of the older kids in middle and
high school finally return
long-awaited after a year of distance
learning
and the president of the national
education association of southern nevada
says
there are different concerns with
teachers as classrooms reopen
we put out more risk than other
classroom teachers because they have to
enter multiple
classrooms
middle and high schools will follow a
hybrid learning plan for the rest of the
academic year and full-time distance
education
will still be an option for those
families who still do not feel
comfortable with face-to-face
instruction so
back out here live we see students
talking with administrators and
you know a lot of excitement in the air
we saw the first people out here just
after
five o'clock this morning to roll out
the red carpet
start treatment for not just the
students but also those teachers who
have been wanting to come back to campus
we're also waiting for superintendent
jara to show up and greet everyone
we'll have that for you on
eightnewsnow.com and also here on 8 news
now
for now reporting live from the far
northwest hector mejia
back to you guys quite the new version
of a pep rally this morning up there at
centennial hector good to see you thank
you very much